[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute mache ich ein ganz kurzes und
schnelles rezept und zwar gibt's
antipasti ich mache rote spitz paprika
die wird eingelegt und die könnt ihr
dann wirklich wunderbar als vorspeise
verwenden oder auch als grill beilage
und selbst wenn die gerade grill könnt
ihr sie super zu bereiten
dafür verwende ich acht rote spitz
paprika hier habe ich knoblauch olivenöl
und weißem balsamico essig salz und
pfeffer jetzt nehmen wir zuerst die
spitze rocker dies bereits gewaschen
ich gebe es jetzt einfach auf ein
backblech und dann kommen sie in den
backofen bei grillfunktion oder ihr
könnt sie auch direkt draußen auf dem
kohlegrill oder den gasgrill schmeißen
die kommen jetzt hier rein dann nehmen
sie am besten die höchste stufe und auch
wirklich ziemlich weit oben dann kann
ich jetzt hier grill große fläche wählen
und dann auf höchste stufe und so lange
grillen bis die oberfläche schöne blasen
wirft und schwarz wird jetzt ist die
paprika fertig ich hab sie zwischendurch
einmal gedreht damit beide seiten
richtig schön dunkel sind und jetzt
kennt ihr das wahrscheinlich dass man
die haut ganz mühsam abziehen muss da
gibt es aber einen trick gibt die
paprika jetzt nämlich in der schüssel da
kommt kaltes wasser rein lasst die zehn
minuten stehen und dann sehen wir die
haut ab und außerdem verbrennt man sich
dann die finger nicht mehr
[Musik]
kommt man jetzt setzt sich die haut ganz
leicht abziehen
[Musik]
da oben nämlich jetzt einfach den
paprika steen noch weg und die kerne
raus
[Musik]
ihr könnt jetzt selber entscheiden ob
die paprika so groß bleibt oder bis er
einfach noch klein schneidet geht es
ganz wichtig mit viel knoblauch arbeiten
die knoblauchzehe entweder reiben oder
auch in scheiben schneiden und dazugeben
die gibt dann das aroma an die paprika
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal vier kleine
der freut sich der macht
und jetzt ist auch ganz wichtig mit
olivenöl und mit dem essig abschmecken
und da müsst ihr einfach schauen wie
groß eure spitz paprika ist dann noch
salz pfeffer dazu
[Musik]
jetzt noch verrühren und dann am besten
eine stunde marinieren lassen
[Musik]
so sieht die eingelegte spiels paprika
jetzt aus ich habs jetzt in ein
schraubglas gefüllt ihr könnt sie so
nämlich auch vor dem grillen schon zwei
drei tage vorher zu bereiten und dann
zieht so richtig gut durch einmal habe
ich jetzt hier auf baguette angerichtet
mit bisschen frischkäse einfach in der
spritzt hülle gefilmt und darauf gegeben
essen kann ich jetzt nicht denn wir
geben gleich noch offene feuer und ich
will jetzt nicht nach knoblauch riechen
aber morgen früh wird es gleich gegessen
da bleiben wir nämlich dann einfach zu
hause
falls ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
dann schaut aufs eis - talk.de vorbei
ich finds eine richtig coole idee vor
allem sehr lecker und schmeckt immer
sehr gut und man hat immer was im
kühlschrank was man auf den tisch
stellen kann also viel spaß beim
nachbacken nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal wie ich es aber zu mutig
und ehrlich ist dann hat er heute abend
keine freunde
nein quatsch war noch spaß
[Musik]